[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a verdict is handed down in vanessa
bryant's lawsuit against los angeles
county hear how much the county has
ordered to pay in the california trial
and clear what paul wanted and it seems
equally clear that they're not doing
that the daughters of the late paul
newman are suing the foundation named
after the philanthropist alleging it
hasn't followed their father's donation
wishes plus the attempted murder and
kidnapping trial of trevor summers
were you worried about your mom or
trevor
yes barry the defendant's daughters
testify in a florida courtroom and later
things get heated in the trial of ohio
versus matthew moore
i'm not going to participate in this
proceeding without the elected county
prosecutor i think this is a shame that
you're going forward lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm your host alison hall in for brian
buckmeyer a california jury orders los
angeles county to pay 31 million dollars
in damages after first responders took
graphic photos of the kobe bryant
helicopter crash after only four and a
half hours of deliberation jurors
awarded bryant's widow vanessa bryant 16
million dollars and 15 million dollars
to christopher chester whose wife and
daughter also died in the crash together
brian and chester brought the civil
lawsuit against los angeles county
arguing first responders took graphic
photos at the crash site and shared them
with others outside of the police and
fire departments the photos show images
of the crash itself and also close-ups
of the victim's remains kobe bryant and
his daughter gianna and seven others
died when the helicopter crashed back in
january 2020. both brian and chester
testified during the trial saying the
photos caused emotional distress and
feared that one day they would be easily
accessible in the end jurors found the
los angeles county sheriffs and fire
departments lacking protocol resulting
in a violation of rights
joining us today is co-host harry austin
and former swat and crime analyst lisa
lockwood lisa let's start with you the
jury determined first responders lacked
protocol when they managed that scene
what type of protocol should have been
in place to protect these families
rights
well there is a protocol in place for
any crime scene accident scene that you
are to render aid first and then
preserve the crime scene and we know
that there were brush fires that day as
well so if you wanted to take
photographs before a forensic team came
over there and did that in order to
preserve it it's perfectly okay
anything beyond that taking pictures for
your own personal use distributing them
showing them to people in you know in
casual settings it's a complete moral
breach because police and first
responders their whole entire job and
career is based on serving and
protecting so
it's a violation of their conduct being
unbecoming and
protocol is set for that and i really
pray that this sets a precedent for all
law enforcement and first responders
going forward to not do this
and terry the jury awarded vanessa
bryant 16 million dollars but
christopher chester 15 million dollars
how do you think they accounted for that
one million dollar difference
allison that's a great question and
unless we actually speak to one of those
jurors we're not going to know for sure
why they did that but in my opinion each
of them should have received the same
amount emotional distress is emotional
distress and both brian and chester they
lost a spouse and they lost a child and
chester just like brian had other
children to raise in fact he testified
at the funeral that he told his wife he
would take care of the boys if she could
take care of peyton so that's emotional
distress and i think that they probably
should have gotten paid the same amount
maybe they did it because she's famous
and the pictures might come up
yeah it is a very tragic story hopefully
that brings some peace to these families
switching now to florida where the
defense calls back-to-back psychiatrists
witnesses in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial in february 2018 a
then 19 year old gunman opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida 17 people were killed
and 17 more injured in october of last
year the gunman pleaded guilty to all
charges that means a jury will now
decide whether he is sentenced to life
in prison or receives the death penalty
weeks after the trial began the defense
presented its opening statement on
monday before court recessed early on
thursday defense attorneys called two
psychiatrists who discussed the
childhood and mental state of the gunman
are you familiar with fetal alcohol
spectrum disorder i am okay
and if you had learned of any uh
prenatal alcohol exposure
that wouldn't have changed your
treatment plan for the defendant would
it not really you still
medicate the symptoms you're seeing
regardless of what the etiology you're
treating the behavior is yeah
and did you get the impression that
linda was doing everything she could to
help the defendant i did
and obviously you learned what happened
on february 14 2018. i did
do you think there's anything about your
evaluations or treatment that would have
led you to think that the defendant
would kill 17 people
no
still ahead on long crime daily a
florida defendant cross-examines his own
daughter after electing to represent
himself
but first paul newman's children file
suit against their father's company
arguing their father's legacy is under
assault
[Music]
welcome back two daughters of the late
actor paul newman are suing the charity
foundation set up in his name susan and
nell newman say the foundation isn't
abiding by their father's wishes when it
comes to giving money to their
charitable organizations long crimes
angenette levy is here to explain
allison you know we've all probably seen
paul newman's newman's own products at
the grocery things like salad dressing
and spaghetti sauce and the money from
the sale of those items goes to charity
through the newman's own foundations but
susan and nell newman are saying that
their charitable foundations are
supposed to get money from newman's own
foundation every year so they can
distribute it to charity and they say
that hasn't been happening now paul
newman set up newman's own foundation in
2005 and laid out instructions about how
he wanted it run the newman sisters say
their foundations are supposed to get
400 000 each year from the newman's own
foundation but in 2020 that amount was
cut in half by the board of directors of
the newman's own foundation now they're
suing claiming a breach of fiduciary
duty and they want 1.6 million dollars
so their foundations can get that money
in order to distribute it to charities
of their choosing
starting four days after paul died
is that you know the leadership and the
board of the foundation has
you know in large part excluded the
family and the very people
that mr newman had directed to be
specifically involved in very particular
ways
excluded them from
the the implementation of his legacy
which is in large part through the
foundation
a spokesperson for the newman's own
foundation calls this lawsuit meritless
and said in a statement to me the
board's philanthropic giving decisions
vary each year and the importance of our
mission requires us to make the best use
of our finite resources best practices
surrounding philanthropic organizations
do not allow for the establishment of
perpetual funding allotments for anyone
including nell and susan newman
now the the attorney for now and susan
newman say look this money is supposed
to go to our charitable foundations this
is what our father wanted and they say
that this is not a meritless lawsuit
allison
thanks anne jeanette terry let's go to
you here it sounds like there were a
number of documents expressing
charitable wishes but apparently nothing
was firmly memorialized do you think
that the daughters have a chance at all
in this case
well i think they have a chance and it
all depends on whether or not that case
is going to be determined by the law
completely or whether or not there'll be
some equitable considerations they did
ask for a jury who i think might look at
this more equitably but according to the
complaint paul newman did express his
wishes in letters and emails and videos
but it doesn't seem as though the living
trust and the last will and testament
actually made that clear and so the
foundation really can
control how it gives and how it runs its
company and it's a difficult situation
for those daughters to be in they know
what their father wanted so hopefully
they'll be able to reach some sort of
settlement at the end of the day so both
sides can end up with what they need one
running the company and two making sure
that paul newman's wishes are really
addressed
and lisa what more do you think could
have been done to enforce mr newman's
wishes and give more control to his
daughter over that foundation
it's as simple as a contract
so
this new organization that took over the
paul newman foundation
the contract that was sent to them they
needed to make sure that it was in there
that there was going to be a certain
amount if you have this company coming
forward now and saying that they're it's
meritless based on how much the income
is and how much they receive prior to
that listen 2020 is when we had the
pandemic so it makes perfect sense if
you open up the books that you're going
to see less sales for
products and this happened across the
country so unless it's in stone and
being in stone means there is a contract
that says that they will receive x
amount per year regardless of
they really the family probably wouldn't
have a leg to stand on and and jeannette
if newman's own foundation has been
around since 2005 paul newman died in
2008 and the family has felt excluded
since then why do you think the sisters
took so long to file this lawsuit
well their attorney andy lee said that
basically they were fearful for a little
while
that they would be viewed as contesting
the will because apparently there was
some language in paul newman's will
saying basically you contest this will
you're out you get nothing but they
maintain that this isn't money for them
it's for their charitable foundations
and that they want to distribute it as
their father wished and as their father
wanted them to receive these funds to
their foundations thank you ann
jeannette coming up on law and crime
daily fireworks in the courtroom when a
prosecutor storms out of an ohio murder
trial plus a defendant accused of
kidnapping an attempted murder opts to
represent himself cross-examination gets
tense when he questions his own daughter
[Music]
welcome back the defendant's daughter
testifies in the florida trial of trevor
summers a man now representing himself
against charges of kidnapping and
attempted murder
prosecutors say 45-year-old trevor
summers kidnapped his wife back in 2017
and attempted to kill her before a
witness facilitated an escape officials
say summers and elisa mathewson were in
the midst of divorce proceedings when he
allegedly plotted a murder-suicide plan
they say summers held his wife captive
in her home and the back of her suv
attempting to kill her twice and raping
her several times summers allegedly
pulled the couple's daughter who was 14
at the time into his scheme when he
asked her to leave a window at
mathewson's house open for him to get in
her sister brynn who was around seven
years old at the time took the stand on
thursday she testified she was worried
for both parents that night but didn't
fully understand what was going on
were you worried about your mom or
trevor
yes barry
and why were you worried
um i just didn't like understand like
like what was going on until like after
like
but yeah i didn't like understand what
was going on
could you hear what was being said
between your mother and uh trevor
i do not remember
just a lot of screaming
do you remember
bran if
i was yelling anything back at mommy
no
you remember if i was saying anything at
all
no i don't remember
the state rested its case thursday
afternoon summers indicated he may
testify as a defense witness and will
decide before friday morning
terry brynn was only seven years old at
the time of the incident and now she's
13. how do you think she held up on the
stand
i think she did a great job she's still
a minor so there was no camera on her
but she sounded so young even at the age
of 13 now she didn't really remember
that much but i do think she made a
couple of points first of all she called
her father trevor and to me that means
she certainly is not siding with him and
she certainly doesn't really think of
him at this point as her father one of
the things she also clarified was
she said that the mom was yelling and i
do think that trevor was trying to make
it seem as though she was yelling and
she was mad but she made it clear on
that stand that her mother was yelling
because she was scared not because she
was just yelling at her dad and i do
think that she overall probably made an
impression on the jury last but not
least the defendant said good to see you
i gotta tell you that was inappropriate
and the judge gave him a glare and he
best not do that again he can't mix up
his role as an attorney and as a father
yeah absolutely lisa let's turn back to
trevor summers if he decides to testify
how exactly would that work
uh believe me i've thought about this
because i haven't seen this i haven't
seen it in my lifetime um the first
thing that i thought it was
ventriloquism because how is he going to
ask himself questions but obviously he's
got a co-counsel who is there i would
imagine that he has pre-written
questions and they would go over
everything that he would like to have
come out but as far as the objections
because he is a he's he's representing
himself and if he's under direct is he
going to be able to object to some of
the questions based on that i don't know
but i'd like to see him take the stand
i think a lot of people would with him
representing himself it certainly is
making for an interesting trial
when we come back a heated start to the
day in an ohio courtroom
ahead of both sides resting in the case
of matthew moore as he stands trial for
the stage
suicide of his wife
[Music]
welcome back in ohio things got a little
heated in the courtroom before the
defense began presenting their case for
the day in the trial of matthew moore as
he faces murder charges for the alleged
staged suicide death of his estranged
wife the trial comes more than two years
after emily noble was last seen the
night of her 52nd birthday celebration
when she and moore went out on may 24
2020. moore reported noble missing but
he reportedly never helped with the
search for his wife over the next few
months then four months later several
women found noble's body badly
decomposed in the woods near the
couple's home her remains were in a
kneeling position with a usb cord around
her neck tied to a tree branch
authorities believe she was murdered and
that her death was staged to look like a
suicide moore was arrested last june and
charged with felony murder and assault
in connection to noble's death before
the jury was brought in on thursday
morning attorneys had a dispute with the
judge then one of the prosecutors
stormed out take a look
yeah i'm sorry but i would object to
going forward anyway right now without
the elected county prosecutor who's on
this case but she chose not to be here
that's not accurate judge okay
okay your objections noted we had a
phone status conference two weeks ago in
which
bishop your objection is noted
okay
i'm not going to participate in this
proceeding without the elected county
prosecutor i think this is a shame that
you're going forward when the court was
you're going to sit here
you're going to sit here you were told
about her unavailability and
specifically told her on the phone not
to cancel that appointment that it
wouldn't be i'll tell you what if you
want to be here for the decision that's
your business well your honor i think
this is outrageous you're going for
without the prosecutors
once testimony did get underway the
defense rested after their second
witness he testified about a test he
conducted with a crash dummy on the
branch where noble's remains were found
after the
static mass test did you do a second
test on the branch
we did and and we called that the
dynamic test and we started by just
hanging that fifth female small female
crash test dummy
to make sure the branch just found the
dummy and then we tried to
uh lift the dummy about six inches
and and give it a little bit of a
dynamic event
so that there was some energy from
gravity pulling on the dummy back down
i really wanted to try to mimic exactly
how the remains were discovered to make
sure the test was realistic as possible
was the branch able to sustain those
five tests
the branch did not fail so i would say
sustain the five tests
and lisa let's start with you here have
you ever seen a prosecutor storm out of
a courtroom and legally could the case
even continue without anyone from the
prosecution team present
no this was the first time that i've
seen something like that um complete
lack of decorum i totally understand
what he was trying to say to the judge
he didn't want to continue the judge was
aware of her not being present for that
period of time and the only way that it
would continue obviously he cooled his
heels and he came back is to have
somebody else pinch hit for
the state's attorney who was not able to
be there or the judge could simply say
let's have an adjournment and give him a
day to resolve the issue
certainly made for a dramatic moment in
that courtroom terry turning now to the
defense council in this case how is she
doing and was this a good witness to
call
well i think she's doing a great job and
it was a very necessary witness diane
monash the defense counsel she's tried
over 100 cases in fact she tried that
case against dr william husell who was
the individual who was accused frankly
of murdering his patients and she got 14
not guilty verdicts for him she teaches
at harvard law school so she is not a
novice her opening statement detailed
what she was going to show and i liked
that she didn't just sit back and let
the prosecution fail she said to that
jury i am going to show you what this
case is all about and this particular
witness was important that witness could
establish that that tree could hold a
body and from a forensic standpoint that
is extremely important the jury has to
understand that this possibility this
suicide could have existed and so that
witness was crucial and really all the
defense needs to do is to make sure just
one of those jurors has some sort of
reasonable doubt and by putting this
witness on she has established that
she's also said she's bringing other
witnesses and if she does that i do
think that the jury will be able to
think about the fact that this case has
doubt and maybe that will be an
acquittal or you know maybe a hung jury
yeah and certainly not a lot of evidence
in this case thank you both lisa and
terry and to our viewers thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you